so recently there has been a pretty big
leak that is suggesting that 13 rising 7
will have 12 cores in 24 threads for
less than $300 with clock speeds above 4
gigahertz on top of this is also
suggesting that there will be the
introduction of a new horizon 9 series
which will have up to 16 cores and 32
threads for just 400 to 500 dollars so
not only would AMD be increased in the
core count and clock speed but they
would also be decreasing the price and
paving the road for seven nanometers
CPUs can AMD actually offer this most
likely will they possibly but despite
whether or not they do offer this a
third gen Reisen
here are some other reasons why you
should wait for 13 rising welcome to
Haris hobbies so first of all is it
going to be a tick year so basically the
big refresh year rise and one was a tick
year and last year risin 2 was a talk
here so as you guys could see risin to
just has small improvements or Verizon
wants to see clock speed improvements
but that's pretty much it
there was no new architecture or big
core count increases it was pretty much
as clock speeds and just other new
minimal things
however with Turgeon risin it will at
least offer a 7 in mere process as a new
big upgrade and next year in 2021 it'll
be a fourth-generation rise in it which
will probably be a talk here so just
small improvements next year and we'll
probably not see a big upgrade until
2021 when aimed you'll most likely
launch a m5 as a result this is going to
be the big last upgrade for a m4 and you
can bet that you will not be left in
dust the following year
next up this leak is suggesting really
really good pricing for the new
generation it is suggesting the rise in
seven thirty seven hundred which will
have 12 hours and 24 threads to only be
$300 and it is also suggesting at the
top and rise at 9 model will have 16
cores and 32 threads and only come in at
$500 but be able to overclock all the
way to five point one gigahertz now I'll
be absolutely outstanding if that
happened but those are some big offers
for those prices thus I'm really not
sure how true this leak will come out to
be however no matter what happens you
can bet that whatever AMD offers will be
great value
and much much better than what endo has
to offer in my opinion I think that a
mule offered an eight-core 16 thread CPU
on a 70 meter architecture with least
five new Hertz overclocking I think that
it will be priced in the mid or lower
300s around over 9700 KS plus you'll
probably also get a really nice stock
cooler with it so overall you will not
be ripped off no matter what AMD has to
offer
now this leak is suggesting a third gen
rising will be revealed at CES next
month and launch soon after however it
is getting very close to CES and we
still haven't heard anything from AMD so
I'm really pleased skeptical about this
one historically md has released their
rise in mainstream CPUs at the end of
march or beginning of April and I'm sure
they will do a save me this year but
even then that's only three months out
and you won't be having to wait much
longer also it is no secret that AMD
CPUs don't have the best RAM support and
there are several RAM sticks that would
simply not wrap the high speeds with AMD
CPUs this Lissa's have really been
shortened but they're still a handful of
popular RAM sticks that are simply not
supported but hopefully with rise in
third generation we will no longer have
to face this issue now it is not that
big of a deal to find RAM sticks that
are compatible with Verizon CPUs but
this is just an additional benefit
Uprising third generation finally rising
the second generation pricing will only
get better with launch of rising third
generation so let's say AMD announces
third-generation Rison and it's just
really not what you're expecting for and
it is just not that great
well at that point you just go pick up
right in second generation CPU or a lot
cheaper and where you could right now
for example the risin 770 hundred from
the first generation of rising launched
for price of three hundred and thirty
dollars but after it launched a second
generation rising is Black Friday you
can get for a whopping 150 dollars even
now you can get for a very low price of
two of dollars so once the second
generation Rison is not the newest thing
that amy has to offer the price won't be
significantly reduced and you'll be able
to save a lot of money so even if worst
comes to worst and rising third
generation is just mediocre
which I really doubt but even if it does
come down to that at the end of the day
you just pick up a new second generation
rising CPU and walk out with some extra
cash in your pocket they can spend
elsewhere overall rising 3rd generation
seems very promising with all the leaks
so far suggesting really great things
with just new architecture more cores
and higher core clock speeds on top of
this is going to be coming out very soon
it'll definitely be better a value than
whatever endo has to offer finally
they'll most likely have better RAM
support and it will not be outdated very
soon and even if it doesn't turn out to
be that great you just pick up a new
rise and second generation CPU and save
some cash on it so that's why you should
wait for 3rd generation rising but
that's just what I'd think what do you
guys think do you take a mule actually
offer this and if not what do you think
they will offer make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments I'm accuses -
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like it
to be the major drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari
I'll see you guys on the next